well we have to do a number of things
and we have to do them all at the same
time mindful of the guiding truth of
what made America and economic success
and that is to put a stronger middle
class at the center of every policy
question that we ask and every answer
for which we search so we do need to
adopt wage policies that keep the
minimum wage not only up and pacing with
inflation but above the poverty line we
need to make the investments in our
country that we used to make in terms of
infrastructure education and innovation
at a higher level than we've been making
it we also need to rein in the reckless
gambling that takes place with our money
and our national economy on Wall Street
we need to refrain from bad trade deals
that have American jobs and and
corporate profits leaving our country
and finally we need to raise Social
Security benefits so that we don't
relegate a whole generation of seniors
to living their golden years in poverty
these are the things when done together
along with many other things that
actually create the sort of consumer
demand that allows our economy to grow
in ways that lift every family
the two areas that are related to our
economy I think have to do with foreign
policy and national defense all of these
things are related to one another I mean
we have to be nimble in a fast changing
world so that we can identify change
before we become victims of it and and
act in ways that make our country the
beneficiaries of that change what does
that mean that means engaging in a more
forcing way these substantial powers we
have as a nation beyond our military
namely our economic our diplomatic and
our healing powers to work with
like-minded nations around the world and
much more collaborative ways than
perhaps we were accustomed to in a world
with dominated by superpowers in the
past I see our politics actually moving
beyond these rather divided and
polarized and self-defeating times to a
much more collaborative and connected
form of politics in other words the
internet governing and the Information
Age the openness and transparency that
you're seeing cities embrace to make the
work of progress in governing more
personally responsive and also more more
more easily verified by individual
citizens all those things I think are
going to converge to create a much
greater trust among not only citizens
and the government that serves them but
also among all of us as citizens and
that's New Republic
you